Instructor: I hope
you're super excited to learn
ES6. I just wanted to have a
quick video, in order to get you
set up for this. First of all,
you need a browser that can
support ES6. Right now, that's
all of the latest versions of a
browser. I'm going to be using
Chrome in this one, but grab the
latest Internet Explorer Edge,
or Firefox, or latest Safari,
and you'd be good to go. Once
you are signed in, go ahead and
you can stream the course by
clicking it here. You can go
ahead and download all of the
videos if you prefer to watch
them offline. Then, you also
want to make sure that you grab
the starter files. Now, starter
files are hosted up on GitHub
here. It's just a whole bunch of
different HTML and JavaScript
files that we're going to be
using throughout the course.
I recommend that you code all of
this stuff yourself, sort of
from scratch. I think it's going
to set in the best. But if you
prefer to just watch them and
then code them after, you can do
that, or if you will just need
to reference some of the code,
it's also available inside of
here. There is a file called
data.js. If you ever need just
an array of things, or a couple
objects, or just some data to
actually work with, then I
recommend grabbing it from here.
I also use this data throughout
the entire series. That's
pretty much it, so enjoy the
course. Make sure you jump into
the Slack channel and chat with
everyone else who's taking it.
Enjoy.